we're told that a cone-shaped grain
hopper and they put the highlight hopper
in blue here in case you want to know
its definition on the exercise it's
something that would store grain and
then it can kind of fall out of the
bottom has a radius of 10 meters at the
top and is 8 meters tall so let's draw
that so it's cone-shaped
and it has a radius at the top so the
top must be the where the base is i
guess one way to think about it must be
the wider part of the cone so it looks
like this
something like that that's what this
first sentence tells us it has a radius
of 10 meters so this distance right over
here
is 10 meters and the height is 8 meters
they say it's eight meters tall so this
right over here
is eight meters
then they tell us it is filled up to two
meters from the top with grain
so one way to think about it it's filled
about this high
with grain
so it's filled about that high with
grain so this distance
is going to be
eight minus these two so this is going
to be six meters high
that's what that second sentence tells
us the hopper will pour the grain into
boxes with dimensions of 0.5 meters by
0.5 meters by 0.4 meters
the hopper pours grain at a rate of 8
cubic meters per minute
so the first quite a lot of information
there the first question is what is the
volume of grain in the hopper so before
we even get to these other questions
let's see if we can answer that so
that's going to be this volume right
over here of the red part the cone made
up of the grain pause this video and try
to figure it out
well from previous videos we know that
volume of a cone is going to be 1 3
times the area of the base times the
height
now we know the height is 6 meters
but what we need to do is figure out the
area of the base well how do we do that
well we'd have to figure out the radius
of the base let us call let's call that
r right over here and how do we figure
that out well we can look at these two
triangles that you can see on my screen
and realize that they are similar
triangles
this line is parallel to that line this
is a right angle this is a right angle
because both of these cuts of these
surfaces are going to be parallel to the
ground
and then this angle is going to be
congruent to this angle because you
could view this line as a transversal
between parallel lines and these are
corresponding angles and then both
triangles share this so you have angle
angle angle these are similar triangles
and so we can set up
a proportion here we can say the ratio
between r and 10 meters the ratio of r
to 10
is equal to the ratio of 6 to 8 is equal
to the ratio of 6 to 8. and then we
could try to solve for r r is going to
be equal to r is equal to
multiply both sides by 10.
divide both sides by 10 and you're going
to get sixty
over eight sixty over eight eight goes
into sixty seven times with four left
over so it's seven and four eighths or
it's also seven
point five
and so if you wanna know the area of the
base right over here if you wanted to
know this b it would be pi times the
radius squared so
b in this case is going to be pi
times 7.5 we're dealing with meters
squared and so the volume to answer the
first question the volume is going to be
1 3 times the area of the base this area
up here which is pi
times 7.5
meters squared times the height so times
six meters and let's see we could
simplify this a little bit six divided
by three or six times one third is just
going to be equal to two
and so let me get my calculator they say
round to the nearest tenth of a cubic
meter
so we have 7.5
squared
times 2
times
pi
is equal to
if we round to the nearest tenth it's
going to be
353.4 cubic meters
so volume is approximately 353.4
cubic meters
so that's the answer
to the first part right over there and
then they say how many complete boxes
will the grain fill
well they talk about the boxes right
over here the hopper will pour the grain
into boxes with dimensions of 0.5
meters by 0.5 meters by 0.4 meters so we
can imagine these boxes
they look like this
and they are 0.5 meters by 0.5 meters
by 0.4 meters so the volume of each box
is just going to be the product of these
three numbers so the volume of each box
is going to be the
the width times the depth times the
height so 0.5
meters times 0.5
meters
times 0.4
meters and we should be able to do this
in our head because 5 times 5 is 25 25
times 4 is equal to 100 but then we have
to think we have one two three digits to
the right of the decimal point so one
two three so this is going to be a tenth
0.100
cubic meters so a tenth of a cubic meter
so how many tenths of cubic meters can i
fill up with this much grain
well it's just going to be this number
divided by a tenth well if you divide by
a tenth that's the same thing as
multiplying by 10
and so if you multiply this by 10
you're going to get 3 3534
boxes
now once again let's just appreciate
every cubic meter you can fill 10 of
these boxes and this is how many cubic
meters we have so if you multiply this
by 10 it tells you how many boxes you
fill up and one way to think about it
we've seen this in other videos we're
shifting the decimal one place over to
the right to get this many boxes
and it's important to realize complete
boxes because when we got to 353.4
we did
round down so we do have that amount but
we're not going to fill up another box
with whatever this rounding error that
we rounded down from
so the last question is to the nearest
minute how long does it take to fill the
boxes
well this is the total volume and we're
going to fill eight cubic meters per
minute so the answer over here is going
to be our total volume it's going to be
353.4
cubic meters and we're going to divide
that by our rate
eight cubic meters per minute and that
is going to give us 353.4
divided by 8 is equal to
and if we want to round to the nearest
minute 44 minutes
is equal to approximately 44 minutes to
fill all the boxes and we're done